Hi, welcome along to Inner Work. I am Dr. Marianne Trent, a qualified clinical psychologist. It's lovely to have you here. So in the main episode this week on psychology, actually I was talking with Dr. Alex Button about all things EMDR and trauma. And whilst the whole episode is really impactful, I thought we'd take a little bit of a deeper dive. So it's that idea that sometimes as humans we will naturally be, you know, avoidant of pain.
你好，欢迎收听《内在工作》（Inner Work）。我是玛丽安·特伦特（Marianne Trent）博士，一名合格的临床心理学家。很高兴你能在这里。在本周关于心理学的正片中，我实际上与亚历克斯·巴顿（Alex Button）博士讨论了关于眼动脱敏再加工（EMDR）和创伤的一切。虽然整集内容都非常有影响力，但我认为我们可以更深入地探讨一下。这就是那个观点，即作为人类，我们有时会自然而然地回避痛苦。
It makes sense because we need to be aversive to pain. It's why when we are, you know, I love with young children, we'll say, you know, keep your hands away from the hob, don't touch the oven, like let's keep ourselves safe. But if we then do burn ourselves or hurt ourselves, we learn that that pain is not good. I am recording this with a broken hands. If you're watching on video, you might be like,
这是有道理的，因为我们需要对痛苦产生厌恶感。这就是为什么当我们和年幼的孩子在一起时，我们会说，你知道的，手离炉子远点，别碰烤箱，我们要保护好自己。但如果我们真的烫伤或伤害了自己，我们就会明白那种痛苦是不好的。我是在手受伤的情况下录制这一期的。如果你在看视频，你可能会想，
has she not learned about pain being aversive? I have. I have learned and it will be interesting when I go back to do reformer Pilates, how that will lay flat for me. I think I will be extra specially careful when I am pressing the pause button to do some more reps in between the exercises. So yeah, I think, especially as a trauma specialist, I definitely do need to be able to go back to the scene of the crime and I broke my arm three years ago and I had, have been back cycling to the area where I hurt my arm because it felt important to reclaim that.
她难道没学会痛苦是令人厌恶的吗？我学会了。我已经学会了，而且当我回去做普拉提核心床训练时，看看我该如何平躺，这会很有趣。我想在练习间隙按暂停键做更多重复动作时，我会格外小心。所以，是的，我认为，特别是作为一名创伤专家，我确实需要能够回到“犯罪现场”。我三年前摔断了手臂，我曾骑车回到我受伤的地方，因为我觉得重新面对那里很重要。
But of course, when it comes to psychological trauma, things that feel ouchy, often especially if we're feeling like we don't have somewhere safe to take that or someone safe to take it to, then we can kind of build these little barriers in our brain or in our behaviour so that we're not having to kind of address that so often because it's a natural kind of pain relief strategy. And another way that people will do that is to look for kind of some anesthetic to life. And that might be ordinary life or it might be that there's kind of trauma elements in there that might feel like they need more. anethitising. So sometimes when I'm working with people and they say, well, I don't drink,
但当然，当涉及到心理创伤时，那些让人感到“哎哟”的事情，通常特别是如果我们觉得没有一个安全的地方或安全的人可以倾诉时，我们就会在脑海中或行为上建立起这些小屏障，这样我们就不用那么频繁地去处理它，因为这是一种自然的缓解痛苦的策略。人们这样做的另一种方式是寻找某种生活的“麻醉剂”。这可能是普通的生活，也可能是其中包含的创伤元素，让人觉得需要更多的麻醉。所以有时当我与人交谈，他们说，嗯，我不喝酒，
I don't do any drugs, I'm not on any medication, but I've got all of these things happening. It's like, wow, well, how are you coping with that? Because you are doing all of that without an aesthetic. And that is not to say that I think the people would need that. But it's to kind of highlight that you are doing that, you know, without anything taking the edge off. So if it feels, feels like it's a lot, that's because it is. And of course, Alex put really nicely in the main podcast episode, that often trauma can present as if its anxiety or can present as if it's depression.
我不吸毒，也不服用任何药物，但我身上发生了所有这些事情。这就像是，哇，那你怎么应对呢？因为你是在没有任何麻醉的情况下完成这一切的。这并不是说我认为人们需要那样做。而是为了强调你确实是在没有任何缓解的情况下做到了这一点。所以如果感觉压力很大，那是因为事实确实如此。当然，亚历克斯在主播客中说得很好，创伤通常表现得就像焦虑或抑郁一样。
And so it's gonna make us kind of slow down, it's gonna make us more hypervigilant, which might then make sleep harder as well, And sometimes with depression, often people might retreat into sleep. But if you are traumatised, then being able to get that sleep is going to feel even trickier. And so often I'm working with people who will be saying, well, I am coping using alcohol or I'm using, you know, my prescribed medication. Sometimes I'm using a little bit more than has been prescribed.
所以它会让我们慢下来，让我们变得更加过度警觉，这可能会让睡眠变得更加困难。有时对于抑郁症，人们往往会退缩到睡眠中。但如果你有创伤，那么能够获得那种睡眠会感觉更加棘手。所以我经常与那些说“我正在用酒精或处方药来应对”的人一起工作。有时我用的比医生开的剂量还要多一点。
Please don't do that. Please, if you find yourself in that position, do go and speak to your GP or your prescribed. but time and time again people are telling me well I'll get in from work or I'll you know come five o'clock I'll find myself reaching for the fridge reaching for the wine reaching for the beer because I can't carry on with this level of thoughts with this level of intrusion with feeling this awful and so it's that kind of seeking to to change your feeling state to change your mood state to change the way you feel and often when we're looking at the window of tolerance it's that desire to bump
请不要那样做。如果你发现自己处于那种境地，请务必去咨询你的全科医生或开药的医生。但人们一次又一次地告诉我，嗯，我下班回家，或者到了五点钟，我发现自己会去冰箱找酒喝，因为我无法承受这种程度的思绪、这种程度的侵入性想法，以及这种糟糕的感觉。所以这是一种试图改变你的感觉状态、改变你的情绪状态、改变你感受方式的行为。通常当我们观察“耐受窗口”时，这就是那种想要推动
yourself either in or out of a different mood state so if we were looking at if someone was feeling really spacey and numb and frozen and dissociated then sometimes they will tell me that they will be looking at something to bump them up a bit so that they feel more normal or the other way around if they're so hyper aroused and agitated, they'll be looking for something to bring them down and that's where alcohol might often be mentioned. But of course, doing this is kind of telling the brain, telling the body that we can't safely exist in the normal window of tolerance bit. And so this is where accessing therapy of some descriptions such as EMDR can be really powerful because it
自己进入或跳出某种不同情绪状态的渴望。所以如果我们观察到某人感到非常恍惚、麻木、僵硬和解离，有时他们会告诉我，他们会寻找某种东西来让自己振作一点，这样他们才会感觉更正常。或者反过来，如果他们处于过度觉醒和烦躁的状态，他们会寻找某种东西让自己平静下来，这就是为什么经常会提到酒精。但当然，这样做是在告诉大脑、告诉身体，我们无法安全地存在于正常的“耐受窗口”中。所以这就是为什么获得某种形式的治疗（如EMDR）会非常有力量，因为它
helps you to live that fuller life, where you're more engaged, where things feel like they come more easily to you. That might be your own career. That might be parenting. That might be just the thing that makes you you. So if you feel that you are suffering with kind of managing post-trauma, please do know that it can be different. People are often. People are often will believe there's no hope ever feeling any different when it comes to trauma. But I know and Dr. Alex would want you to know it absolutely is. Change is possible. I hope you found this special episode of Inner Work Helpful.
能帮助你过上更充实的生活，让你更投入，让事情感觉更容易处理。这可能是你的职业，可能是育儿，也可能只是让你成为你自己的那件事。所以如果你觉得自己在应对创伤后压力方面感到痛苦，请务必知道情况是可以改变的。人们往往认为，当涉及到创伤时，永远没有希望感觉好转。但我知道，亚历克斯博士也希望你知道，这绝对是可能的。改变是有可能的。希望你觉得这期《内在工作》特别节目很有帮助。
I love your thoughts and your feelings on it. Please do let me know in the comments or by coming to connect with me on social media where I'm Dr. Marianne Trent everywhere. If you like my episodes, if you like the content, please do share. Please do tag so that we can help psychology actually and inner work to develop a wider audience. That means we get even better guests every time. Thank you so much. I'll be along for the next episode of Inner Work, which will drop on Wednesday evenings in the UK.
我很想听听你对此的想法和感受。请在评论区告诉我，或者在社交媒体上与我联系，我在所有平台上都是“Dr. Marianne Trent”。如果你喜欢我的节目，如果你喜欢这些内容，请务必分享。请务必点赞，这样我们就能帮助《心理学》和《内在工作》吸引更广泛的受众。这意味着我们每次都能邀请到更好的嘉宾。非常感谢。我会在下一期《内在工作》中与大家见面，节目将于英国周三晚上发布。
Thank you again. Take care. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
再次感谢。保重。本集目前还没有评论。点击转录稿中的任何句子即可发表评论。